Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Getting Over It.
*sigh*
I... have calmed down
I've relaxed...
I, uhh...
I've tried very hard to...
collectively think about what I've learned...
...from the last one...
and also...
Take that...
...into consideration for what I'm doing...
...in the next round.
So, I just gotta get over these goddamn umbrellas but thankfully, you know I should be grateful for the things I have
instead of like wondering of what I don't have...
wwwoooiiieecchhh [which]
is a will to LIVE!
Oh...
Please, just...
OH...
I should be thankful for what I have...
and not-not grateful for what I don't have.
Any lost progress is a... opportunityYYYYYY
to SUCCEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEED AGAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAIN!
I don't like you.
Okay...
Nooo, no, no, no ,no, no.... Ahhhh, ok.
Oh my god...
k
Alright! MARMELADE!
alright...
MARMELADE, MARMELADE, MARMELADE, MARMELADE, marmelaDE, marmelade
Marmelade marme lade ooh marme lade marme lade  marmeladö. Okay, not wait
Okay, not quite there...
Just scraping the tippy-toppy...
ouh
That was a quick thrust,
buddy-boo.
Okay, set me down...
ouh
Phew...
Theres a time for...
quiet contemplation,
And then theres a time for, AHH NO!
I'm over here now!
ouh
Okay, alright...
Is this the way I'm supposed to go?
Ah
No-NOO
no-ah
OOOUUUUUUUUUUUEEEAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAIIIGGH! NO!
*gasp*
WWWHHHYYYYYY?!?!?!?!?
OH-GOD-NO
OH. FUCK. ME. IN. A. GOD AAA. AAAAA. AAAAAA!!!
*cough*
Euugh
OOAAAUUU
NOOO
*heavy breathing*
If I lose, everything...
I will...
I will
kill AGAIN.
Okay.
No,no,no,no,no,no,no NOT what I wanted.
not-AAAHHH what I wanted!
ok
So I HAVE to go over there...
with the boxes!
That's a definite yes-NOOOAAAAAIIIGGHHH
AAAAAaaAAAAAHHH
AAAAH
AAAOOHH
AAAAOOHH
AAAOUHHH
AHHHH
AAAEEHH
AAAHHH
NNOOO!!!!
OH MY GOD, OH MY GOD, OH MY GOD, OH MY GOD!!!
I AM GONNA DIE!!!
I'M GONNA DIE!!!
I'M GONNA FUCKIN' DIE!!!
no, no
no, nO NO-aahhhh
*Heavy breathing*
no-NO STOP
What are you doing?!
What. Are. You. DOING?!
WHAT
ARE YOU DOING...
WITH YOUR LIFE?!
MEEEEEEE
WHAT AM I DOING WITH MY LIFE?!
I can be doing anything!
BUT-
NOOOOOOOOO
OH MY GOD!!!!!!!!!
NOOO
NOOOOO
NNNNNOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
ah
AH
AAHH
GOD
AAAHHH
AAAHHHH
AAAHHHHHHH
why...
whY?
Why?
Wh-NNNOOO
NNOOOAAHH
NO!
*a pained silence*
I'm gonna die...
I am going to die here.
I am going to die
I am going to die.
This game...
Will kill me.
This game
I'm not joking, this game will kill me.
*PAIN*
Oh, FUCK OFF with you, you piece of SHIT.
FUCK OFF.
I know I've done this part before.
fu-
one small step back
one SMALL step back
I know it's-ough
...not this fucking part again...
and then just GENTLY
Like a fuckin' butterfly.
ahhhh
ok
no!
no.
There we go.
There we go!
OK! Good news, we have officially made it back to where we were
just a little bit ago
*deep voice* nooo
that's not how we do-
*Gasp*
oh, why? why?! why?!
I don't understand you.
'Cause, it changes position based on where the camera goes, too.
So if the camera moves, your mouse moves, too.
I can hold my mouse completely still!
If the mou- if the cameras moving, then I'm moving
MMMVAAAGHHH
You know you dind't have to make this game, developer. You DID NOT have to make this game!
*Gasp*
Why?
MMVVV-NOOO
THAT'S EXACTLY HOW I FELL DOWN LAST TIME.
YOU WILL-
WHY?!
ARE YOU DOING THAT?!
NOOOO
GOD
DAMN YOU!
Oh fuck...
I made it.
Not out of choice...
...but out of necessity.
OK, stop.
ok...
...so SOMEWHERE, there's a safe place to drop here.
Very-
See, I didn't move my mouse at all. That was the camera moving.
ok, I see it
ok...
I see it.
ok..
so what I gotta do...
is angle,
push off
oh, uh!
oh my god.
ok..
*Gasps*
ok, alright, ok
I never thought I would get back to this point-
so you know, they've got something-there is something to that whole shtick  about what ever the FRICK they were talking about!
Okay.
Alright everyone, please a moment of silence this moment
*Gasp*
This might be the most important maneuver of my life
*Gasps*
uh
HUH OH HO! HO!
*Sigh of relief*
...What?
What are you talking about?
I don't wanna swallow a baseball bat.
I don't even wanna swallow this bullshit game!
oh god
ok..
So I think-I think that OH- NO, NO
STOP STOP STOP STOP STOP STOP
oH my god
so the answer is, I have to swing- I can't push off because of the angle of this chair.
I have to swing.
I have to do a swing-launch
into
that
NOOO NOOO NOOO NOOO
STOP STOOOPPPP
NOOOOO NNOOO NOOO nooo NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO NOOO NOOO!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
GOD
I JUST
WANT YOU TO
STOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOP!!!
Shut up.
MMMMMM
why?
Why?!
WHY?!
why?
Why?
I can launch my selves a thousand miles when I don't want to
but when I want to launch my self, NOTHING
NOOOOO
no, oh no
no, NO, OH NOO OH NOOO OH NOOOOO!!!!
AAAAWWHH, FUUUUHUHUHUHUHUHUUUUCK!!!
FFFFUUUUUUUUUUUUUHUHUHUHUHUHUUUUUCK!!
FUUUUUCK!
AAWWW GOOOD
Oh that's it for this episode!
I'm done.
I can't do it.
I can't do rage games...
I cannot do it, I can't, I can't do it! I'm gonna do it! I'll be back in the next episode
Thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always
I'll see you...
in the next video...
*painfully says* Buh-bye
*Outro music*